alors la pandémie est elle devenue une
endémie le combat contre la comédie 19
devrait-il à ce stade-ci davantage
ressembler au combat contre la grippe
saisonnière on l'a vu il ya plusieurs
experts qui se prononce de plus en plus
ouvertement sur ces questions notamment
vous docteur karl raid se vous êtes
jeunes rappelle microbiologistes
infectiologues et spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
général juif de montréal bonsoir oui
alors on va trancher tout de suite la
question si on est en mesure de le faire
pandémie en demi on en est où vous
semblez croire qu'on est en face
d'endémie désormais
non ce que je dis c'est qu'on est en
train de passer d'une phase de pandémie
à endiguer le passage où se fera pas de
façon brusque donc le 1er mars 2022 la
pandémie ne finit pas et leur déni
commence c'est une facette une
transition son espèce si vous voulez
c'est comme une espèce de rivière qui
arrive dans l'océan et et l'eau douce se
mélangent à l'eau de mer mais entre la
salinité de l'océan est là l'eau douce
ce bail ier un dégradé entre les deux
donc la pandémie c'est quelque chose qui
va arriver vers un état endémique c'est
à dire un état où le virus va persister
dans notre environnement pendant une
période très longue période possiblement
des années et on va devoir vivre avec
apprendre à vivre avec ce qui ressort
vous dirait de ce quand je discute avec
tous mes collègues en maladies
infectieuses
ailleurs dans le monde où ailleurs au
canada les gens partagent à peu près le
même concept
mais c'était quand vous dites apprendre
à vivre avec le virus dr weiss ça veut
dire quoi concrètement dans notre
contexte annuler ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
mis toutes les mesures en place on les a
mis en place parce que on a une peur que
le système hospitalier soit complètement
débordé qu'on ait trop de monde et qu'on
soit plus capable d'être étonnant donc
ce qu'il va falloir faire il va falloir
s'assurer qu'on mette en place des
mesures pour que les gens qui sont à
risque d'être hospitalisé avec l'arrivée
de beaucoup de médicaments d'anticorps
monoclonaux de nombreux médicaments qui
vont arriver et surtout avec la
vaccination que ces gens là bien
vacciner les gens à risme lorsqu'ils
vont attraper la colline on aura des
façons de les garder à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital de les traiter le plus vite
possible pour ne pas qu'ils en orge et
le suspect le système hospitalier
oui dans ce contexte là on vivre les
autres feront peut-être un peu vite
comme ils feront un rhume ou une grippe
dans le passé et puis dans ce contexte
là on retournera à une vie qui est
relativement normale avec encore
certaines mesures dans certains aspects
mais on peut pas continuer à avoir la
qu'ovide 6.0 ou 7.0 en essayant d'avoir
la même méthodologie qu'on a eu pour la
cinquième vague où les vagues
précédentes et même la cinquième vague
était complètement différente de la
première ce qu'on a vécu dans la vraie
vie en termes de traitement ça n'a plus
rien à voir avec le début de la partie
ben voilà donc les les comparaisons
peuvent être hasardeuse entre une vague
et l'autre mais les moyens que vous avez
vos qui colle à notre disposition pour
revenir disons le comme ça la normale
ils sont existants lala les traitements
monoclonaux la vaccination des gens
vulnérables
alors certains nous entendre et se
disent pourquoi se le dise peut-être
pourquoi pas maintenant commencer cette
transition
ben on commence on en donne des
médicaments et nous entraînent des gens
avec des anticorps monoclonaux en
administre les médicaments par la bouche
à des gens qui sont des populations à
risque sont positifs pour la copine qui
ont des facteurs de risque qui risque de
compliquer non mais je veux dire les
mesures sanitaires pourquoi pas l'élever
maintenant si ces outils donc vous
évoquez ils sont là à notre portée en ce
moment c'est là le questionnement qu'on
entend de plus en plus oui mais parce
que premièrement on a raté un petit peu
la vaccination pour la troisième vague
trop tôt trop précocément donc là on a
un rattrapage de vaccination qui tu es
en train de se faire deuxièmement on a
connu dans le système hospitalier une
vague qu'on n'aurait peut-être pas dû
connaître donc là il faut laisser passer
et définir cette vague là même si elle
est dans sa fac plutôt descendante pour
sa phase plateau donc j'avais déjà dit
que jusqu'à la mi-février la saison va
être difficile mais que l'éclaircie est
le printemps va commencer à arriver
après ça aussi bien pour là que vit que
pour le vrai printemps dont on est
jusqu'à je vous dirai encore les deux
prochaines semaines dans une période
difficile où il faut mettre des mesures
en place pour faire redescendre le
nombre de cas s'assurer qu'il ne
remontera pas et éventuellement passer
par à autre chose par la suite et
surtout
au point de vue social au point de vue
psychologique s'assurer que la
population finissent par suivre parce
qu'il ya actuellement une réelle fatigue
pandémique au sein de la population même
au sein de gens qui sont doublement
vaccinés qui maintenant pour toutes
sortes de raisons et je les encourage à
aller chercher la troisième dose se pose
parfois des questions devant toutes les
contradictions qu'ils ont pu voir en
terme de deux recommandations
vous le sentez que l'élastique est étiré
au maximum que l'adhésion est de plus en
plus ténu un point où ça devient
critique
mais je sens que l'adhésion diminue chez
des gens qui sont très vaccinés qui ont
fait la queue pour avoir leurs vaccins
qui sont pas du tout des gens quand les
vaccins qui ont écouté les
recommandations qu'on leur a fait depuis
deux ans à la lettre et qu'ils se disent
j'ai fait tout ça et finalement je me
mets un couvre feu chez les enfants
peuvent pas jouer ok je peux pas faire
si je peux parler au restaurant donc je
peux pas écouter un concert dont les
gens se demandent qu'à ce moment là mais
alors à quoi ça a servi ça a servi
beaucoup il faut pas oublier que sans le
vaccin la vague au micro aurait été une
catastrophe
si vous pensez que ça a été difficile
si on était arrivé avec une vague au
micron sans vaccin mais on le voit chez
les gens pas vaccinés on aurait eu
quelque chose de bien plus terrible donc
le vaccin a été créée utile les vaccins
ce que ça fait ça protège contre la
maladie sévère ça vous empêchera d'aller
à l'hôpital d'aller aux soins intensifs
et surtout de mourir medhat inverse vous
avez dans des contextes récents évoqué
des réticences quant à certaines mesures
qui ont été adoptées très récemment la
en évoquant le fait que cet thème
n'avait pas de base scientifique
alors quelles sont ces mesures qui selon
vous non pas nécessairement lieu d'être
ou qui devrait être levé un peu plus
rapidement que d'autres
mais vous savez quand on a dit par
exemple on devait faire porter des
masques à des jeunes qui avaient joué au
hockey on peut se poser la question que
lorsque vous avez des adolescents
doublement vacciner en pleine santé qui
sont asymptomatiques et qui font un
sport est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
dans une arena qui est ouverte ou encore
plus part sont à l'extérieur est ce
qu'on a besoin d'en faire porter un
masque il n'y a pas vraiment six ans en
arrière de ça c'est clair est-ce que le
risque zéro existe non le risque zéro
n'existera jamais mais d'un autre côté
il faut équilibrer sa en mode des jeunes
des adolescents qui me faire activités
qui peuvent plus le faire et le fait
qu'ils ont un risque très minime
d'attraper la copie qu'ils ont un risque
très minimes de la propager et qu'ils
ont un risque surtout très minime des
taux de tomber malade donc c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les enfants sont
retournés à l'école il ya un risque en
renvoyant les enfants à l'école mais
c'est un risque calculé est acceptable
et c'est nettement mieux pour être à
l'école mais en terminale risques vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure c'est la
capacité du réseau de santé et
d'absorber les patients qui doivent être
traitées pour la coved 19 dans une
perspective de levée des restrictions
sanitaires ou de certaines d'entre elles
ce qui pollue de toi-même de craindre
les conséquences de tout ça on en est à
coire but 2500 d'hospitalisation
aujourd'hui 184 soins intensifs au
québec
regardez il n'y a pas si longtemps on
nous disait que me l'hospitalisation
allait mettre le réseau est sous haute
tension on est monté jusqu'à 3500 le
réseau a très bien tenu dans leur ait pu
monter encore plus haut et le réseau
social est adapté donc oui c'est le
chemin du coup je crois pas j'en suis
certain et donc est donc de façon
pratique s'il fallait ouvrir plus
d'unité et créé plus d'une attention on
l'aurait fait néanmoins c'est pas idéal
parce que ça a empêché beaucoup
d'activités médicales il ya beaucoup de
chirurgie qui ont été annulés il ya
beaucoup de traitements qui ont pas été
administrés les gens ont même peur de
venir à l'hôpital ce qui est un problème
d'ailleurs nous on est obligé de
rappeler des patients pour leur dire
pourquoi vous avez manqué votre rendez
vous parce que c'est des gens qu'on n'a
pas vue depuis un an des fois qu'ils ne
suivent plus vraiment leur traitement et
qui nous disent pas on a peur de venir à
l'hôpital ou même des fois ils sont
gênés de venir en nous disant qu'on
l'entende vous êtes débordé on n'ose pas
vous déranger alors que c'est pas ça
qu'on veut au contraire donc on veut pas
ses dommages collatéraux
persiste et continue d'affecter la
population de toutes sortes de sons j'ai
un collègue ophtalmologiste qui me dit
qu'il ya des gens qui deviennent
aveugles parce qu'ils n'ont pas leur
traitement adéquat et leur chirurgie
pour leurs locaux donc donc il ya toutes
sortes de d'impact la queue qui sont pas
mesurés et facilement mesurable et c'est
pour ça que on peut pas se permettre
d'avoir un système uniquement
unidirectionnelle et n'oubliez pas de
40% des gens qui ont la corrida
l'hôpital ne sont pas à l'hôpital pour
l'aco ville test positif mais leur
couleur leur admission est pour quelque
chose d'autre donc même dans les 3500
hospitalisations les jambes et la copie
mais il n'avait pas tout cela qu vite
comme diagnostic de spécialisation
principal ouais ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'on doive nécessairement baisser la
garde ça reste sérieux c'est une
question d'équilibré finalement c'est ce
qu'on doit comprendre dr karl weiss
merci beaucoup de nous avoir partager
votre vision des choses
ça fait plaisir bonsoir et mature avoue
avoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit